You're an interesting man.
Scott Lang
You're an Avenger.
Have I killed you before
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
Marvel is releasing Ant-Man and the Wasp
Quantumania and I had a chance to see it,
so this will be my review.
There's so much we have to talk about.
Make sure you go see this movie
as soon as possible.
Do not wait.
If you felt disappointed
with what Marvel was doing in Phase 4,
this movie is the beginning
of what everyone has been waiting for.
I'm doing an IMAX ticket
giveaway for the movie.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber.
Just post your favorite moment
from the trailers in the comments.
And since I am posting this video
a couple days before the movie comes out
publicly,
please don't post spoilers on the video.
Anything from the trailers they've
released publicly is considered fair game.
My full Breakdown.
Easter Eggs Post-Credits Scene videos will
post later this week after it comes out,
but the movie is what I would consider
the true beginning of the post Avengers
endgame era of Marvel.
Even Kevin Foggy is kind of building it
that way like this.
This is the beginning of everything.
The whole idea during Marvel sagas
is that there's meant to be clear
villains, overarching goals
that everything is building towards with
this really propulsive sense of direction.
And we really didn't
have that during Marvel Phase four.
But during the movie Ant-Man,
Cassie Lang, Hope, Hank Pym, Janet
van Dyne are all pulled into the Quantum
Realm by Kang the Conqueror.
When Cassie inadvertently opens
a link, Kang tries to use Ant-Man
to escape
the quantum realm where he was trapped
and is acted like a makeshift prison
with the threat that if Ant-Man doesn't
stop him, he could potentially destroy
all of reality
and win the Kang Multiverse War,
which they set up
with the events of the Loki series.
So there are a lot of connections
to everything in Marvel because the movie
is meant to set up Avengers five, Qing
Dynasty, Avengers six, Secret Wars.
They pretty much everything.
They're doing during this saga of Marvel,
the multiverse saga
as they're calling it,
And it's meant to be Marvel
putting the smallest guy literally
and metaphorically, Ant-Man
against their most powerful villain,
is like Leroy
Jenkins, the movie The Other Avengers.
This is why you don't try to solo The
Boss through this.
Well, and
Marvel Phase four was mostly meant to be,
then trying out
totally new concepts and characters
like the phase of Let's Try a Thing.
We had such a successful run
with the Infinity Saga
movies, Avengers, Infinity War, Avengers
Endgame were so intense.
Let's just chill out for a moment
and try some stuff.
Cut to a couple of years later,
they tried some stuff out
and now it's time to get going again.
Like Marvel's version of Get In, Losers
were wrecking the multiverse.
There were a couple of solid Marvel
Phase four movies
like Spider-Man,
No Way Home, the Shang Xi movie.
A lot of stuff was solid, a lot of stuff.
There's all kinds of reasons
wound up being kind of mid, though.
So if you're disappointed in a movie
like Thor, Love
and Thunder, which felt like
it was all over the place with its comedy
in its serious moments,
or when it tried to be serious, Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania
is sort of the antidote to that.
It's meant to be the beginning of Marvel
Phase five.
It has this propulsive force to it.
Thanks mostly to the efforts
of Jonathan Majors as Kang the Conqueror.
There's so much
we can say about his character.
He is so fantastic.
He's done a bunch of other good stuff.
He's also releasing Creed three relatively
soon, and he's going to be wrecking
Michael Jordan Killmonger versus Kang,
if you want to think about it that way.
He's been blowing up all over the place
like he was fantastic
as the he who remains version of Kang
during the Loki series.
He'll also be coming back as other
variants of Kang during Loki Season two.
In this movie,
he is meant to be playing the worst
variant of Kang
the Conqueror
across the entire multiverse,
and it'll remind you what it felt like
seeing Thanos walk right over the Avengers
during Infinity War.
Like, just completely roll all over him.
But what if Marvel decided to do that back
during Marvel Phase one
instead of just teasing Thanos?
Like,
what if they did a Thanos movie in phase
one and just called it
something else, like an Iron Man movie?
All the actors were fantastic.
Paul Rudd as Ant-Man has been great
in all his Marvel movies.
He's great is non Marvel movies too.
It almost seems like he's
aging in reverse too.
Like there's some secrets
he's figured out that we don't know yet.
But the real star of the movie is Jonathan
Majors as Kang the Conqueror,
He takes Josh Brolin's villain performance
as Thanos to a whole new level.
Not only is he just amazing to watch,
one of the most fun things about him
is that he plays most,
if not all, of the other variants of Kang,
and each one is meant to have
a very distinct vibe and personality.
Really good example.
That is, during the Loki
series, he's playing
more of like a Willy
Wonka crazy version of the character.
In this movie.
Kang is meant to be just like a full blown
Thanos level villain
version of the character.
One of the big things that sets him
apart from Thanos, that makes him feel
so different as a villain is that
he is as much at war with other variants
of himself, like he's very literally
and metaphorically at war with himself
as much as he's at war
with the other Avengers like he'll do for
what they all
do together after a while where Thanos
only really cared about The Avengers.
So Kang in this movie hates
the other variants of Kang almost as much,
if not more, than he hates
all the other versions of The Avengers
from different universes.
Taking the concept of self-loathing
to a whole new level,
we'll continue to see many other variants.
Like I said, during Loki season
two other Marvel movies and theories.
Kevin Foggy
said one of the reasons why they cast
Jonathan Majors and particularly to play
this character, is because he could
pull off all the different versions
and make them feel so distinct.
He said.
His performance in this movie as this Kang
is mostly inspired by Julius Caesar,
Alexander the Great, Genghis Khan,
Napoleon in Exile,
because we're talking about him
being trapped
in the quantum realm, great rulers,
conquerors, each in their own right.
To some people, they were heroes.
To some people they were also monsters.
He really tows the line in this movie,
but they do want to remind you.
No, no, he is actually a villain.
Marvel started to get a lot better
with the way it writes its villains
to remember all the Thanos was right.
Memes after Avengers,
Infinity War in Avengers Endgame.
The whole idea with the best Marvel
villains is that even if you condemn
what they're doing, like erasing
half of all life in the universe,
you only understand where they're
coming from and see their point.
Like, terrible person has said something
that you agree with.
Technically, you're
trying to help the universe survive,
but you are definitely a monster.
It's the same vibe with this Kang
the Conqueror.
Marvel wanted to establish their new
Thanos level overarching villain.
That's who he's meant to be
like the villain of the MCU.
Now, even though we're talking about
the multiverse, I still use the term MCU.
You should really think of it
as the Marvel
Cinematic Multiverse because of what's
happening with Spider-Man, No Way Home,
and all the other Fox Marvel movies
being canonized to the MCU.
They do a good job in this movie of making
you understand why he would want to win
the Kane Multiverse war
and kill all the other kangs, erase
all the other timelines but his own.
They do a good job of getting you to root
for the character
like you will be cheering for Kane
to do Terrible things,
even though they are
definitely terrible things.
They get
just you wait.
After Avengers five Qing Dynasty
people will be saying Kang was right,
and ultimately
I think he's going to come off
being a better character than Thanos was.
Like Thanos great villain in the MCU.
Great characterization.
I think Kang
will be even better than that.
Even though a lot of the movie
is dedicated to setting up Avengers
five Qing Dynasty, Avengers
six Secret Wars,
it didn't suffer from the classic Iron
Man two problems
where Marvel used to get criticized
for hijacking their movies,
turning them into glorified teasers
for other spinoffs and future movies.
It still felt very much
like an Ant-Man movie,
which is a lot of larger Avengers
level stuff going on in it.
The director, Peyton Reed,
even said that we wanted this
to feel like a big Avengers level event.
Paul Rudd did a fantastic job,
as he always does, balancing
comedic moments with the really hard
drama.
Really good example of that
is this scene here from the trailers.
I'm an Avenger, but everywhere
I go, people ask me the same thing.
How many holes do you have?
Seven holes.
Oh, and everywhere
I go, people tell me the same thing.
Thank you, Spider-Man.
At the core of the movie,
it's all about his relationship
with his daughter Cassie, and what he's
willing to do for her next to Kang.
I would say
Cassie Lang is probably one of the biggest
newer characters that Marvel reintroduces
in a bigger way, not only because
they recast the actress from Avengers
Endgame, Emma Furman with Kathryn Newton.
They pulled an Iron Man
two like they did with Rhodey,
recasting him with Don Cheadle.
There's no multiverse trickery
going on there.
It's just a simple recasting.
They also gave Cassie Lang
a huge upgrade, just in terms of her
role in the larger MCU.
She's meant to be the Stinger version
of the character from the comics
in a lot of her arc in the movie.
It's meant to set up Young Avengers.
I don't know if Marvel plans on doing that
as a Disney Plus series or a movie,
but you probably notice them slowly
setting up the young Avengers
with all the different
comic book characters
that were on that original roster.
Kathryn Newton did a great job.
She's meant to feel like a chip off
the old block,
so her personality is very similar
to Scott Lang's.
She's meant to be a budding engineer
like he is too.
If you didn't remember,
Scott Lang is an engineer.
He's meant to be really smart.
They just usually use him for comedy
in like her father.
She gets into trouble all of the time,
causing a lot of the problems
that they had to solve in the movie
and that she'll continue to have to solve
in future Marvel movies and series.
We call that a Spider-Man problem.
Wouldn't be Spider-Man movies
if he didn't cause
all the problems
that he has to fix during his movies.
Did it work?
No. Pretty much all the other
main characters had way more to do than
they did in previous movies.
Like everyone gets way more action
Scenes, even Hank Pym and Janet
Van Dyne in for a long time comic book.
Fans of the wasp, Michelle Pfeiffer steals
a lot of this movie as Jennifer.
And not only is she just fantastic actress
The wasp also a really cool character.
I still think that Jonathan Majors
is probably the best
in the movie as his version of Kang,
but Michelle Pfeiffer comes pretty close.
There's so much new law
in Easter eggs in the comics
because a lot of the movie
does take place in the quantum realm,
and they treat it
like this whole alternate universe that
we've never really seen before in detail,
and they just barely get into it.
The vibe is a little bit like, Honey,
I shrunk the Kids mixed with Alice
in Wonderland in a Wizard of Oz, with Kang
being the Wizard in that first trailer.
They even use Elton John's
Goodbye Yellow Brick Road.
And one of the other things
I really loved about
the movie is that it wasn't afraid
to get super weird in comic book.
We like super deep cuts.
We're talking modok
They weren't afraid to go there
where normal movies would just avoid
doing a character like that.
And I feel like they pulled
that character off pretty well.
Just in terms of the pace of the actual
movie, The first act takes a little while
to get going.
They spend a lot of time
catching you up with
what's happened to Ant-Man,
the other since Avengers Endgame.
He's basically leveraged his celebrity
from endgame, saving the world.
It's become public knowledge,
like most people around the world
know what the Avengers did,
and he's been able to use that
to earn a lot of money.
Like he's written
this book, Look out for the little guy.
They use that for a lot of comedy
early on in the film.
Also, the idea that even though
he's earned a lot of money,
most people don't really care about him
because he's such a small, metaphorical,
literal character, like the old man
confusing him for Spider-Man
just because Spider-Man is so much
more popular in real life and in the MCU.
A lot of those funny moments, too,
like taking the piss out of the character,
is meant to set up the stakes
for the rest of the film.
Explain
why he's literally, metaphorically,
the smallest avenger
facing the biggest villain.
Kang He's like the Leroy Jenkins
of the MCU in this movie.
The original score, the music was great.
I love Kane's theme music.
I hope Marvel uses some of it again
when we see other Kang
variants and Loki season
two other Marvel movies like Each Kang
Variant has similar sounding theme music,
but each is a little different
just to suit their alternate
personalities.
Generally, the movie is going to be
a breath of fresh air.
For those of you that are wanting Marvel
to show some real direction
in their movies, an overarching plot like
Yay, Finally things are getting started.
Things are actually happening.
This is the true beginning of this next
Avengers saga
and you will be cheering for Kang
and all the other Kang variants
to just continue wrecking the MCU
in the biggest possible way.
Like I cannot wait to see the mess
that they're going to make of the MCU
the next couple of years.
It does feel like a lot of the overall
Marvel
hype will come back heading into Avengers
five and Avengers six after this.
The same way that that first Iron Man
movie was so solid, did such a good job
of hyping
people up for the first Avengers movie.
There are two post-credits
scenes Do stay after the credits,
just like a normal Marvel movie.
They're both great
and I will do a full Post-Credits scene
video later this week and a full breakdown
and Easter eggs for the entire movie.
Because there is so much stuff
to talk about.
There are so many cool
Easter eggs in here.
Like I said, it doesn't overburden
the movie though.
Do not wait to go see it.
And once you do have a chance to see it,
post your reactions in the comments
and please don't post spoilers or at least
anything that wasn't in the trailers.
We'll get into all that
in my full videos later this weekend.
I'm still in the middle of working
on a bunch of Super Bowl trailers
because there were so many.
I'll post those as soon as possible.
The next one should be
my Mandalorian Season three trailer video
and that will be like the next big series
that I do.
Episode videos for everyone.
Click here for my Guardians of the Galaxy
Super Bowl
trailer video
and click here for my flash trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.